good morning John a month and a half ago
I got on a plane flew to Los Angeles
California first off the plane in-n-out
burger my gosh it was a fantasized show
second stop my hotel when I was asked by
the check-in person whether or not I was
there to party seeing no sign that I was
here to party I assumed he was joking so
I would send something be effective like
duh what part of this package with the
baggy eyes and the nerd
thirty-four-year-old dirty t-shirt where
a guy makes you think that I'm not 100%
turn it doubtful what turned out he was
not joking because he then told me 20
different parties that were happening
within a block and the dress codes for
those which I had no way of chief turned
out I was not just in Los Angeles John I
was in Hollywood staying at the
Roosevelt Hotel advertised on Google
Maps as having a celeb friendly
nightclub and pool I don't know what
that means it was a secret while I was
in LA and that annoyed me because so
many interesting and weird things
happened and the whole point of being a
video blogger is that when weird things
happen to you you get to share them but
now I can share the reason I was in Los
Angeles I was there as part of this
thing where YouTube is promoting YouTube
channels they were taking pictures and
videos of me and Michael Aranda and
Caitlin Hofmeister for the scishow
promotion print advertisement did
television advertisement campaigns which
are now a thing in the real world all
over the place in Chicago in Los Angeles
in New York and on television during The
Walking Dead premiered during the Big
Bang Theory during Late Night with Jimmy
Fallon Walking Dead premiere was viewed
by 17 million people and all the people
who didn't TiVo through the
advertisements saw me what do they think
what do they think about probably not
much usually when you see an
advertisement you're like oh hopefully I
subconsciously influenced them into
thinking that science is still cool and
that they are still curious about the
world no matter what zombie pandemic is
on the way here's the thing about
Walking Dead zombies they've been dead
forever and they're not eating anything
there's not enough humans left to create
fuel for them but somehow they are
magically able to continue moving what
powers them are they photosynthetic
maybe they've somehow tapped into dark
energy and that's powering them if we
could end the zombie apocalypse and
capture some of them and put them like
in hamster wheels with like a brain on
the other side of the wheel and they
could just climb after it forever it
would be
finit free power we could go from the
zombie apocalypse to a complete utopia
I'm saying anyway how I feel about being
on TV and on the side of buses and
subway cars is that I don't know how I
feel a big piece of me understands that
this is a big deal and it searches the
rest of the me for the thing that I'm
feeling about it and it is unable to
find a feeling the disconnected from me
thoughts are like is this good for
scishow and I hope it is because I think
that more scishow is better for the
world because we really do need to be a
more scientifically literate society and
I think that scishow does a fairly good
job of that as compared to television
science stuff and then another piece of
me is are these campaigns in general
it's more than just scishow good for
online video as a thing the goal the
campaign isn't about scishow it's about
making YouTube seem like a legitimate
place to spend your time as a viewer and
as a legitimate place for advertisers to
spend their money it's about welcoming
far more people and also more money into
this medium than has ever been here
before
and I'm a little ambivalent about that
because as the YouTube community becomes
so big and multifaceted that it breaks
from that singular YouTube community
into plural YouTube communities YouTube
as a thing is a little bit less special
if it's mainstream which is why I'm so
extremely happy that vlogbrothers is way
too weird to ever be actually mainstream
and we are dedicated to that we will not
allow log brothers to be unwired enough
for it to be mainstream
this has to be weird I just grabbed you
right by the neck the pizza John has to
hump the puppy sized elephant while
smoothly pooping in agloe New York death
to Penny's John I'll see you on Tuesday